foreign
so what you are seeing here the
collapsing of these people is not a
reflection of a reality
it is more a reality of a fear of a
feeling of a nightmare this was the part
in the film that more than a dream
became a nightmare
foreign
[Music]
is feeling kind of comfortable walking
in a city that he hasn't walked in a
long time
or the nature of an immigrant once you
leave your country for so long you know
that even one thing you cannot go back
Alejandro wanted to use this wide angle
lenses I felt that he was his way of
writing and telling the story visually
the whole film is photographed with two
lenses with anamorphic lenses which are
these lenses that photograph the
landscape of Mexico in an incredible way
and the actors are very present Sylvia
you is very present we we are around him
we are and we see his world mapped
around him
Silverio is on a walk into the past you
know he's going to walk into his paths
or the past of his of his country of
Mexico
to create these um we mix things from
the from the past five decades you can
see that in the vehicles in the cars and
the props
we modified awnings we modified the
shops that were there
[Music]
our first conversations with Alejandro
we decided just to keep him in one
costume throughout the film because we
didn't want to confuse the spectator
if we were going to abstract Silverio
from the color world that we have we
went through many ideas first to have
him all dressed in black but we thought
it was his funeral so we worked in this
color palette we did so many camera
tests to find the correct color and
texture in Silverado's jacket so we
decided to abstract him not completely
out of color but like just in the shade
of greens and the opposite of all the
the background and his family that have
this vibrant colors that sort of
represent our culture
again
the first body fall down followed by the
hundreds of bodies they represent all
the people that have been disappearing
in our country
no
no the chemicals okay
we decided from a point of view of
costume to do a mix of different eras
because this hasn't just happened now
it's been happening for the past six
decades
[Music]
[Music]
the sound is exquisitely moving from a
Cumbia
to the sound of the bodies collapsing
and this Cumbia that is always in Mexico
this contradictory of energy and
electricity and joy with that around us
we have this time lapse shot that we
have to make one year in advance to get
this lighting right all the time in the
street we have to wait for months we
have to close thousands of stores to
negotiate with them to create this
atmosphere
we had to break it down in in different
ways
we created a matching floor of of the
street which celebrity walks in the
stage so so and we put the lighting and
screens all the way around in order to
to have the change of light that we
needed
it was a tactical challenge when you
read the script and you know what you
are going to have to go through with
your team and some with the visual
effects helping us but it was always
always triggered by the Human by The
Human Side of the carrier but Silverio
[Music]
some elements of sound they don't sound
like wind no or like rain
what makes them sound is the actual
surface
the same happens with loneliness or
empty spaces
[Music]
and that tells you
I'm I'm the only one here
it's uh not about the reality of the
city you know it was about the memory
sound
we didn't want to create the night with
the lights on the idea for me was that
this should be more than a nightmare it
was a metaphysical feeling
showed us some serial paintings that he
loved from kiriko and Paul delvo
not really a day for night you know it's
more like a early morning that never
ends
the main place of the soccer is really
the center of the of the city we're in
the big Massacre of the tennis
streetland happened it's always full of
demonstrations full of people full of
elements but in this case we managed to
have it empty for us
we broke the scene basically in two big
pieces one was the soccer log by itself
with some smoke and and Silverio walking
and then we matched the soccer law in
the studio where we created that pyramid
of bodies
you can plan you can have the elements
and then we start placing the bodies
with Alejandro and then using some water
and blood and we started to make like a
tableau it was almost like painting it
was a very beautiful moment that moment
I I will I will keep it always
[Music]
we're really at the at the search of
something you know
we're playing with reality and
stretching reality
everything had a meaning and a purpose
all these life-changing and all these
sound contrast it's what we all wanted
to express through a very single stroke
of emotion as we know it said a film is
Just a Dream being directed
[Music]
again
[Music]